so just as a bit of a review if we take
the members of a certain species that
share the same area we call that a
population
population all of the organisms in this
particular population will be members of
the same species there could be other
members of that species that aren't in
that same area and they wouldn't be a
member of this particular population
and a certain area won't have just one
or doesn't tend to have just one species
in it so we could call this population
one you might have other populations
there of a different species so this is
another species right over here all of
them combined in the same area we could
call this population
population two and if you take and we
could obviously have many more
populations there if you take all of the
populations in a given area and you you
get there's flexibility on how you
define that area or define that region
you take those together so you're really
taking all of the living things in a
certain area we call that a community
the community of populations
now the community only consists of
living things the biotic factors so let
me write that down
biotic biotic referring to the living
things in a certain area but if we want
to think about not just the living
things but also the non-living things in
that region so i'll write abiotic let me
do that
in another color
so let's take out let's take the abiotic
factors or the abiotic environment
and once again we're sharing the same
region
and that is flexible on how you define
that region you put all of these things
together and then you get your ecosystem
your ecosystem once again it could be a
very small region it could be a very
large region but it's made up of all the
living things the biotic factors and the
non-living things the abiotic factors
now what we're going to think about in
this video is just the types of
ecosystems that you might have think a
little bit about it and also begin to
think about how the the different
factors
interact with each other how there's a
conservation of matter where within an
ecosystem matter tends to go from one
form to another you also have a flow of
energy energy tends to enter an
ecosystem
in form of light and that energy gets
transferred from one organism to another
and sometimes even involving the
non-living things eventually becoming
getting turned into actual heat
now in terms of the types of ecosystems
i already mentioned there's a lot of
variety there this right here is a
picture of a tide pool at half moon bay
not too far from where i live i've
actually been to the tide pools at half
moon bay and you could consider one
particular tide pool
both the abiotic factors the water and
and the rock there as long as
as well as the biotic factors the
starfish
the the sea anemones and and and
whatever else might be living there
those combined that could be an
ecosystem you might get to say that the
entire beach is an ecosystem you might
say that the entire region is an
ecosystem once again it depends on on
how much you want to zoom in or how much
you want to zoom out and you can zoom
out a good bit this rain forest right
over here this is the amazon rainforest
you can consider the whole rainforest
and ecosystem or maybe you just want to
study maybe you just want to study
what's happening in this exact region
right over there you could also consider
that an ecosystem you can consider
what's happening in the river itself an
ecosystem or maybe one part of that
river and as you notice i'm talking
about some ecosystems that are on land
and some that are in water and that is a
general way of one way of classifying
them so an ecosystem you could have it
on land
you could have it
on near in the water so we could say
it's aquatic
and then even within aquatic you can
have ones that you have salt water or
partially salty water and these are
called marine
and the main marine ecosystem we're
thinking about the oceans and and things
like that
and then you have fresh water ecosystems
like if you are in the upper amazon that
is fresh water that is flowing so we
could say fresh
fresh water
non-non-salty water and even though it
looks like rivers are big and there's a
lot of fresh water around us obviously
we need fresh water to live most of the
aquatic ecosystems are marine are not
involved fresh water fresh water is a
very small subset
now this is just a few examples even
your body you could view your body as a
whole as an ecosystem you could view
parts of your body as an ecosystem you
could look at just you could look at
just a fraction of if this is my hand
right over here
you could just take a little square
there and you could consider that an
ecosystem and you can think about the
different bacteria that are there other
types of microorganisms that are there
and how they are interacting with the
non-living things the the air how they
are
interacting with uh the oil on your skin
with the dead skin cells and also how
they're interacting with the lot the
living skin cells and you yourself
now since we're in the
since we're in the
we're focused on how we can classify
ecosystems one thing that's often done
is
classifying land ecosystems into various
categories and
right over here
we have depicted the major types of land
ecosystems in on our on our planet and
where you might find them and these
different types of land ecosystems these
are called biomes
biomes and as you can see from this
diagram tropical forest you could find
it right over here that's the amazon
rainforest you can find it in africa you
can find it in southeast asia you can
find it
in in central and and even southern
north america
you have boreal forest which you'll find
in more northern latitudes savannah
desert tundra chaperone polarized
tempered forest temperate grasslands and
these are just helpful for thinking
about roughly
the types of ecosystem or ecosystems we
would find in those regions and it's
typically most determined by
temperature
moisture the climate
both actually the climate and the
terrain and the types of minerals that
you would find there that tends to be a
pretty good indicator for for what it
will be like what the life would be like
but even with that said there could
still be a lot of variety for example
the sonoran desert that is right over
here in the southwest united states in
the northwest mexico
this is a desert and there and there's
deserts all over the rest of the planet
but they won't have they might be
similar in a lot of ways but they won't
have the exact same climate or the exact
same
abiotic factors or the exact same biotic
factors so for example right now i'm
going to show you a picture pictures of
the sonoran desert and the rock desert
that's on the island of boa vista boa
vista is right over there you really
can't see it's a very small island off
the coast of africa and as we see
in these diagrams or in this picture you
don't have to be an expert to recognize
that okay these are both deserts they
both look dry there's not a lot of water
here
but they are also very different the
sonoran desert looks to have uh at least
a lot more life than the rock desert
have here it's appropriately named the
rock desert because it seems at least to
the naked eye it looks like all you can
see is rock
so biomes once again it's a very rough
high-level way of classifying land
ecosystems but even though
the same biome can be very very uh two
things with that are categorized in the
same biome could be very different